thanks to blueprint lsat for helping me
get into my dream law school and
supporting the channel
I was thinking maybe we could go out
sometime
no you're a dork I'm in law school oh
boy
I'm in law school is a terrible pick-up
line at least I don't think it's a good
pick-up line is it a good pick-up line
have I wasted my life now you're
thinking like a lawyer
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because today we have a special
treat we are covering perhaps the most
highly requested legal movie of all time
on this channel Legally Blonde I've
waited so long to hear you say that I
have a special connection to this movie
and I was saving it for something
special and that time has arrived legal
eagle has 1 million subscribers which is
just incredible a lot of laws have been
broken along the way and a lot of
hashtag not legal advice has been handed
out so without further ado let's dig in
to Legally Blonde put on your pinkest
tie this is gonna be just like senior
year except for funner find your
fluffiest dog and let's get in to
Legally Blonde I plan on running for
office someday and I fully support that
warning you know that right absolutely
but the thing is if I'm gonna be a
senator by the time I'm 30 I need to
stop yeah so the US Constitution says
that to be a senator you have to be at
least 30 years old so he literally
cannot be a senator before he turns 30
this guy is kind of a dumb-dumb you have
no idea the pressure that I am my family
has five generations of Senators my
brothers in the top three at Yale Law so
that would be a big deal if one's
brother was in the top three at Yale Law
School because although Harvard is
probably the most well known law school
in the country
Yale is continually ranked the best law
school in the u.s. Yale sends more
people to the Supreme Court more people
clerk for the Supreme Court Neal is
generally considered slightly more
prestigious than Harvard even though
Harvard is probably better known so yeah
that would be a big deal so you're
breaking up with me because you're
afraid your family won't like me
everybody likes me well East Coast
people are different East Coast people
are different true that Harvard Law
School that's right but that's a tough
three school oh I have a 4.0 yes but
your major is fashion merchandising okay
so this is a pretty common misconception
that to go to law school you need to
have some pre-law major or you have to
be a Poli Sci major law schools in my
experience really don't care that much
about what your undergrad major is
because none of those majors really
prepare you for either law school or
becoming a practicing attorney so the
fact that L has a degree in fashion
merchandising probably won't matter that
much at all in fact seems like she went
to a good school the same school that
her boyfriend went to so I doubt that
her particular major is gonna have much
of an effect now on the other hand it
could actually help her law schools are
inundated with people who have a
political science degree or English
majors or history majors so if you have
a degree that is interesting and stands
out or shows you want to go into a
particular legal specialty then that can
actually help you get into law school
but for the most part your undergrad
major has no effect whatsoever
what are you backups I don't need
backups I'm going to Harvard well then
you'll need excellent recommendations
from your professors okay and a heck of
an admissions essay alright so that part
is true in order to apply to law school
almost everyone uses the same online
system and in order to complete your
application for most schools you have to
attach at least two letters of
recommendation and using that same
online system almost every law school
requires a personal statement which is
an essay that you'll submit to those law
schools and at least a 175 on your L
sets yeah so a 175 on the LSAT is a very
very high score and that is exactly the
kind of score that you need to get into
that school
now the LSAT is judged on a score from
120 at the bottom to 180 at the hind I
have no idea why they chose those
particular ranges why it doesn't go from
zero to a hundred but it's 120 to 180
and if you're anywhere above 170 out of
180
then you're in the 99th percentile of
all LSAT test takers so your chances of
getting into Harvard at that point are
pretty good you're gonna need this
your scrunchie my lucky scrunchie it
helped me pass Spanish you pass Spanish
because you gave professor Montoya a lap
dance after the finite yeah luckily that
does not age well and from my admissions
essay I'm gonna tell all of you at
Harvard why I'm gonna make an amazing
lawyer all right I'm sure I don't need
to tell you that it's not appropriate to
send the video version of your
admissions essay and in fact there's no
way to upload that onto the law school
application system and if you did mail
it in they'd probably just throw it
directly into the trash so there is a
time in a place for thinking outside of
the box but your admissions essay is not
that time and it's not that place
neither type of opera or neither type of
grabs on sale be either type of jazz and
neither type of opera is on sale so what
they're hinting at here with this
dialogue is a specific type of question
that actually does show up on the LSAT
it's called a logic game and generally
you're given a fact pattern with a bunch
of logical variables and you have to use
logic and other tools to find out the
correct answer based on different things
that happened in the fact pattern and
these are the kinds of questions that
people tend to have the hardest time
with because they require
problem-solving mentality and certain
problem-solving tools that people just
don't necessarily know intuitively so
you have to learn that with an LSAT
class and there's a whole cottage
industry of people that try and teach
you how to do well on the LSAT because
it's such a counterintuitive test
this is actually a pretty good scene
it's showing that she's taking practice
LSAT exams before she takes the actual
LSAT and what's even better is that
she's not just taking her practice exam
in a deadly silent room but she's taking
it in a room with a bunch of
distractions which i think is actually a
habit that can really help in most kinds
of tests when you're taking the LSAT or
any test for that matter you're not
taking it under ideal circumstances
things aren't going to be perfectly
silent which is often the way that we
study for exams and the way that we take
practice exams so you're likely to do
better if you practice in an environment
that is not conducive to actually doing
well
[Music]
179 on the LSAT would be an
extraordinarily high number basically a
perfect test it means out of the 100 or
101 questions you might have missed one
or maybe two questions in the entire
exam of course this was recorded before
the LSAT required a written portion of
the exam as well at the time it was all
multiple-choice so good job Elwood's
that's very impressive
of course she could have made it easier
on herself by using blueprint LSAT like
I did but nope nope I'll wait till the
end I'll tell you my story at the end of
this video wait a second I'm my social
events calendars missing you're what
social events you know mixers formals
clambakes trips the Cape yeah so they're
making the joke about Law School that
there's a lack of social events because
that's largely true especially in your
first year of law school one else who
are first-year law students are under so
much stress that there's really not that
much time for social activity and
sometimes you do what's called bar
review which is usually on Thursday
night which is not actually reviewing
things for the bar you're just going to
a bar to drink so if anyone says they're
going to bar review that's what they're
talking about that being said as two and
three L your schedule does open up a bit
so you have more time for recreation and
there are things like law school formals
and dances and get-togethers and you
know still more bar review for drinking
because it's you know law school but
there are actual social directors and
things like that so it's it's not crazy
for her to have assumed that there would
be actual social activities even as a 1l
this is the part where we go around in a
circle and everyone says a little bit
about themselves
Hey how you doing I'm Mina Dweck's there
got a PhD from Berkeley in women's
studies emphasis in the history of
combat and last year I single-handedly
organized the March for lesbians Against
Drunk Driving hello good times yeah so
there you have yet another person who
doesn't have the standard pre law degree
or Poli Sci degree law schools love to
have a diversity of thought and a
diverse student body so that's a great
example of someone who's not your
run-of-the-mill law student and yet
they're theoretically going to Harvard a
legal education means you will learn to
speak in a new language you will be
taught to achieve insight into the world
around you and to sharply question what
do you know that is very true I would
say that one of the most important
takeaways I had from law school was just
to dig deep to be skeptical and to make
sure that you check out all of your
premises before you jump to a conclusion
so in that respect this law school
professor seems to have a handle on
things does anyone know who spoke those
immortal words yeah Aristotle are you
sure yes but you'll be willing to stake
your life on it I think so what oh god I
hate this style of teaching but I've
also had professors who had a similar
teaching style that was very aggressive
very much about breaking the student
down before building them back up again
I happen to think that this is a
terrible way to be a professor but
unfortunately this style of teaching
does exist so I can say that this
repartee is not completely unrealistic
it has happened in front of me before
now I assume all of you have read pages
1 through 48 and are now well-versed in
subject matter jurisdiction who can tell
us about Gordon versus Steele
oh my god the Socratic method of
teaching I'm getting PTSD just thinking
about it so in a nutshell the Socratic
method is based on Socrates who went
around not so much pontificating but
asking questions of his students until
he revealed so-called deeper truths
through these questions that went far
below the surface this is a style of
teaching that you'll find in most law
schools I don't know why but law schools
tend to be the last bastion of
educational places that use the Socratic
method nobody seems to do it it's really
a terrible teaching style number 1
stresses the students out because
they're on the hot seat and they could
be peppered with questions that they may
or may not know the answer to but on top
of it when you're the one that's being
asked those questions your brain tends
to shut down and you don't really
remember the actual exchange and the
craziest thing is
most law schools don't give any
classroom points for participation or if
they do they give a very small amount
for class participation so all the
stress that this Socratic method causes
doesn't actually count for anything when
you're in class it's insane
in addition to competing against each
other for the top grade in this class
you will also be competing for one of my
firm's highly coveted for internship
spots next year where you will get to
assist on actual cases I've never heard
of a full professor at Harvard or any
other law school for that matter also
being a full time partner in a law firm
at the same time or at least I hadn't
until I reviewed how to get away with
murder which has a similar conceit and
is similarly in sanely ridiculous it's
also ridiculous to be offering an
internship to one of his students based
on the best grade what you will see is
that a professor will give a TA award to
one of the highest performing students
in his or her class in other words if
you do really well in that class you can
come back the next semester or the next
year and be a TA for that particular
class which is a highly coveted award in
kind of a mark of distinction and having
a job your first year summer in law
school is really important because when
you come back from the summer that's
when you tend to do interviews with the
top law firms so while this particular
award seems very ethically dubious the
general concept is accurate and you're
trying to compete for 1l summer jobs and
to get a TA award and be a TA for a
professor ms Woods would you rather have
a client who committed a crime malum in
SE or malum prohibitum neither why is
that I would rather have a client who's
innocent yes I hate using legalese and
Latin it's a common misconception that
lawyers are going around spouting Latin
all over the place in reality you really
want to minimize the amount of legalese
that you're using because you don't want
to use overly complicated words and
phrases you want to be as persuasive as
possible and really as down-to-earth as
possible so whether you are drafting
something to a judge or talking to a
jury it's actually very rare that you're
going to use obscure
and phrases like this friggin nonsense
this is kind of a dumb question what's
with the costume you know I feel like we
barely get to see each other since we've
been here I know I'm so busy these case
studies and hypos so this is actually
kind of an accurate depiction of the
stuff that first-year students have to
go through you're inundated with cases
that you have to read because Law School
uses what's called the case method so
law students tend to brief every one of
those cases before class and at the end
of the year when you're giving your
final exam or in your midterm you're
given what are called hypos and hypos
refers to the type of essay questions
that you tend to get on your final exam
for the most part in law school you're
you're tested based on a hypothetical
set of facts you're given a huge fact
pattern and then you have to answer all
these questions like how many crimes are
being committed and explain why
basically so that's a little throwaway
line that's accurately describing what
most law students go through come on
you're never gonna get the grades to
qualify for those spots wait am I on
glue or did we not get into the same
lost corner so she's actually making a
really excellent point and this is
another common misconception about law
school which is that people assume that
the quote/unquote smartest people are
the ones that are gonna get the best
grades in law school as if knowing more
law and knowing more facts will
translate into better grades at the end
of the semester and in fairness that is
sort of the case in college in high
school we're memorizing things by rote
will generally result in better grades
when you regurgitate those facts back to
the professor but this is not the case
in law school once you get into the same
law school all bets are off there is no
reason to assume that L would not be
able to get as good grade or better
grades than the rest of her classmates
these kind of exams are all about
application it's about thinking like a
lawyer where have I heard that before
[Music]
it would be kind of like an engineering
exam where you're not asked about
formulas or about the history of
engineering you're asked in your final
exam to build a car from scratch that's
kind of what you're doing but from a
legal perspective so people often screw
this up and the people who get the best
grades are generally not who you think
they are you need reasonable belief that
your claim should have like evidentiary
support that was a stupid question and a
nonsensical answer
I completely agree this is not a good
example of a dialogue between a
professor and a student at this point in
the semester
[Music]
okay that is a reasonable question to
ask assuming this is a Crim law class
and that was a reasonable answer there's
a concept in criminal law called mens
rea a' it means to be guilty of a
criminal offense and you have to have
the mental capacity to have done the
crime itself sometimes committing the
same action is a crime and sometimes
it's not a crime and it depends on the
mental state so when she's saying that
the diminished capacity negates mens rea
that's sort of correct that would mean
that the affirmative defense of
diminished capacity might negate the
mental state required to be guilty of
the criminal offense who's asking
I'm Elle Woods miss fauna Fontes
attorney oh no L don't do that that is
bad news do not do that
come again do you understand what
subject matter jurisdiction is yeah I
didn't think so well do to habeas corpus
which means produce the body that's
absolute nonsense in this context you
and miss bono Fonte had a common law
marriage which heretofore entitles her
to what is legally referred to as
equitable division of the assets yeah I
mean that's a real phrase that gets used
in divorce proceedings but it probably
doesn't apply here this is insane come
again
due to the fact that you've retained
this residence miss Ponte Ponte is
entitled to full canine property
ownership and will be enforcing that
ownership right now oh boy okay so what
l has done here is she has pretended to
be an attorney she hasn't finished law
school she's never passed the bar and
she has absolutely no right to call
herself an attorney and when you do that
that's called the unauthorized practice
of law she has held herself out as an
attorney she's essentially committed a
fraud against this other person and as a
result she's committed a huge ethical
violation so if anyone ever finds out
that she committed this unauthorized
practice of law while she was at Harvard
Law School she would probably be barred
from entering the bar in virtually any
state in the United States
I hate to see this both for the ethical
lapse of judgment and as just someone
bullying a layperson ten people saw her
downing Cosmopolitan's of the caribou
club all I know is this not Brooke
that's touching out but we need an alibi
all right I think they're confusing
alibi with an alternate suspect and
alibi is something that you have to show
you were not the one responsible or
could not have done the crime that was
committed an alternate suspect is
someone else who could have committed
this crime and they want to have both
but they already know their client
doesn't have an alibi because she was
the one that found the body so they're
gonna have to do their best to come up
with an alternate narrative but it's
important to note here that while an
alibi or another suspect might be nice
to have it's not necessary for a
criminal defendant to be acquitted you
might want to have it but again the
defense doesn't have the burden here
they don't have to prove anything it's
the prosecution that has to prove their
case beyond a reasonable doubt which is
the highest burden in all of criminal
law we got two interviews tomorrow
Gerard and Bobby you're gonna handle the
ex-wife in an hour and according to this
communique from the prison Our client
apparently had a visit from her sister a
Miss Delta Nu how much time are these
law students spending on this murder
trial they're in the middle of their
first semester at Harvard Law School
Harvard is not like Yale in that they've
done away with letter grades if anything
letter grades are bigger and badder in
Harvard than anywhere else so how are
they spending hundreds of hours a week
on this murder trial team as an intern
while ignoring their law school and
their law school grades they're gonna
get terrible grades they're gonna fall
behind in their reading in all the rest
of their classes this is not smart if
they actually want passing grades in the
classes that they're already in did you
ever take mrs. Windham on a date yes
where a restaurant in Concord where no
one could recognize us and how long have
you been sleeping with mrs. Windham
three months and your boyfriend's name
is Chuck right
alright alright so this is a little
ridiculous but what this attorney has
done is employ a tactic that is actually
used by actual trial attorneys and that
tactic is to get the witness in a habit
of agreeing with you you ask a string of
questions and it doesn't have to be as
rapid-fire is here but you ask
unobjectionable questions that you know
the answer to and you know the witness
is going to answer yes or no and it's
only at the end after you've trained the
witness do you ask the question you
really care about and by then it's too
late
so it actually can work like that a
little bit sort of part of a part of me
what am I ask mister Salvatori I was I
was confused you see I thought you said
friend Chuck is just a friend all right
the judge has to keep control over her
courtroom otherwise it's prejudicial to
the defendant but what happened outside
of that witness's testimony is not
evidence that the jury should not be
able to take that into account the
defendants really really should call
that man Chuck to the stand and ask him
questions about his relationship with a
prior witness I'm feeling they're not
going to do that which is basically
malpractice but that guy should be on
the stand so you can get his reaction to
the testimony and establish that the
other witness has perjured himself I
think it's time to discuss your career
path have you thought about where you
might be somewhere associate oh this is
not good
not really I know it's very competitive
well you know what competitions really
about don't you
it's about ferocity carnage balancing
human intelligence with animal diligence
I don't like to focus on the animals
knowing exactly what you want and how
far you're gonna get it how far will
oh okay all right I called it what a
creep what a creep as we've seen in
things like suits this is an example of
quid pro quo sexual harassment now the
professor wasn't quite as explicit as
the episode of suits that we reviewed
but unfortunately what he's done here is
an implied that she could get a summer
associate position and potentially take
a full-time position with his firm if
she agrees to his sexual advances that
is classic quid pro quo sexual
harassment it's super gross and I hope
she sues his because that guy's a jerk
and all right so now it is time to give
Legally Blonde a grade for legal realism
on the one hand there are some accurate
depictions of Law School studying hard
for the LSAT and getting a good grade
that would get you in and lots and lots
of case reading on the other hand lots
of legal tropes that make absolutely no
sense complete gibberish when it comes
to legal discussions and absolute
malpractice in the middle of a trial so
I will give legally blonde a very very
gracious B - I object on the other hand
one of the accurate things about Legally
Blonde is that Elle Woods studied her
ass off for the LSAT got a good score
and got into one of the top law schools
in the country which is a very similar
story to my own in fact the guys who
started blueprint LSAT were actually my
personal LSAT tutors I was actually able
to raise my LSAT score 15 points by
studying and learning the tricks of a
trade and that's how I was able to get
into one of the top law schools in the
country getting a good score on the LSAT
is by far the most important thing to
getting into a good law school it's more
important than your grades more
important than your college is more
important than your extracurriculars
blueprint helped me learn the tricks of
the trade when it came to logic games
and reading comprehension their methods
are top-notch you can take a live class
you can take an online class you'll have
fun while preparing for the LSAT but
more importantly you're guaranteed to
raise your LSAT score or your money back
blueprint LSAT students raise their LSAT
scores by an average of 11 points and in
fact blueprint students are 6 times more
likely to score a 170 or above than
average
LSAT takers and blueprint has branched
out not just from l SATs but to the MCAT
too so whether you're thinking about law
school or you're thinking about medical
school
blueprint has you covered and legal
eagles get access to a huge special
discount you get 33 percent off of
blueprints online courses when you sign
up for six months which is probably how
much you should be studying for the LSAT
anyway so if you're studying for the
LSAT or the MCAT this summer and you
want a special discount just go to the
link in the description or go to
blueprint LSAT comm slash legal eagle
and you'll get a discount you can't find
anywhere else
again that is blueprint LSAT comm slash
legal eagle or just click on the link in
the description clicking on that link
really helps out this channel and I
appreciate it so do you agree with my
grade for Legally Blonde leave your
objections in the comments which I will
either sustain or overrule and check out
this playlist over here with all of my
other legal reactions including suits
and how to get away with murder and
better call Saul so just click on this
playlist and I'll see you in court